Money Heist's fifth
and final season has begun
and it really has
raised the roof.
Well, technically
it dropped the roof
with explosions
and all-out warfare
seizing the Bank of Spain.
Money Heist has always been
a difficult show
to second-guess.
Would you ever have
predicted Arturo
going full-Rambo
in a forklift truck?
Yes, that happened.
The wait now begins
for the final episodes
on December 3rd,
and it has left fans
wondering what lies in store
for The Professor
and the gang.
So, let's round up
the juiciest fan theories
about what might happen
in the final part
of Money Heist.
Do be careful
if you aren't up to date,
there are
plenty of spoilers!
The first half of Part 5
ended with a massive shock,
as a wounded Tokyo
made a brave last stand
against the special forces
and sacrificed herself
to give bald terminator
Gandía
an explosive farewell.
As the first character
we ever met in Money Heist,
saying goodbye to Tokyo
was never going to be easy,
which maybe explains
why some fans
are holding out hope
that she isn't really dead.
The main thinking
behind this theory
is that Tokyo
is the show's narrator,
and many believe
she's retelling
the story of the heist
having survived it.
Some even speculate
she's telling the story
to Nairobi's son, Axel,
to explain
how his mother died.
An even wilder theory
is that the entire
Money Heist story
is being made up
in Tokyo's head
and that it's actually
her way of coping
with the tragedy
of losing her boyfriend
in the first bank heist
we see in flashback.
If either of these
narrator ideas were true,
Tokyo would need to be alive
to tell the tale.
There's also the popular
fan theory from Part 4
that when Nairobi dies
she enters heaven or limbo
and joins all the robbers
who've previously died:
Oslo, Moscow and Berlin.
But earlier
in that same setting,
we also see Denver,
The Professor and Helsinki,
which could foreshadow
their deaths.
Tokyo isn't seen
in this heavenly garden,
so could it mean
she survives?
Stacked up against
this theory is the fact
that in Money Heist's
"Making Of" documentary
From Tokyo to Berlin,
we clearly see Tokyo actress
Úrsula Corberó
give an emotional farewell
to the cast and crew.
If they faked
that to trick us,
it would be a deception
worthy of The Professor.
But, hey,
keep the dream alive, right?
While the bank robbers have
a rough time in Part 5,
Berlin has a much
smoother ride
in flashbacks
to an earlier heist
he pulled off in Copenhagen.
The only explosion here
was the popping
of champagne corks.
These flashbacks reunite us
with Berlin's wife, Tatiana,
and introduce his son,
Rafael.
As neither Tatiana or Rafael
have appeared
in the Bank of Spain heist,
it has fans wondering
if these two have a role to
play in the current robbery.
As Berlin had been planning
the Bank of Spain job
for many years,
it might not be
a coincidence that his son
ended up learning a skill
that could play a part.
His whole education
just to prepare him
to crack open banks,
and you thought
your parents were pushy.
Another theory
is that Rafael
is destined to team up
with Tatiana,
potentially having an affair
with his dad's new wife.
After all,
as Berlin explains to him…
If you really want something
in life,
you have to steal
it from whomever has it.
And the look
on Rafael's face
suggests
he has something in mind.
If he were to team up
with Tatiana,
could they throw a spanner
in the works
of The Professor's plans?
Fans theorised
back in Part 3
that letting Tatiana in
on the Bank of Spain plan
was a bad idea.
By the way, she loves the
Bank of Spain heist.
She knows.
Could she sweep in
with Rafael
to take the prize
at the last moment?
Time will tell.
However,
there's another theory
which could take Money Heist
in a very different
direction.
Some fans think Rafael
is actually
The Professor's son.
With his glasses
and slightly awkward
social skills,
he certainly
has more in common
with the brainy mastermind
than suave Berlin.
This would also
provide an answer
to one of the biggest
mysteries of Part 5.
When Alicia Sierra
is interrogating
the captured Professor
in his lair,
she accuses him of lying
to his brother, Berlin.
I'm trying to set the facts
straight and tell the truth.
You've been lying
the whole time.
You didn't even tell
your brother the truth.
What truth
is she referring to?
If The Professor
was Rafael's dad,
that would be
a pretty big secret
between the brothers.
Or maybe
it's just more mind games
from the devious Alicia.
Speaking of Alicia,
the interrogator
we love to hate
has lots of fans
guessing about
whether she can be trusted
going forwards.
You'd think that
The Professor helping her
during a traumatic birth
would bond them for life,
but careful viewers don't
believe she's on Team Heist.
For starters, she was
clearly seen hiding
a pair of pliers
up her sleeve.
Now, she could just
be planning
to help Marseille
put together that crib,
but fans think
she's planning
to cut The Professor's
communication with the bank.
Eagle-eyed viewers
also point out
a moment during the birth
where Alicia
is clearly seen reading
The Professor's documents
as she searches
for equipment.
Could it be
that she's figured out
The Professor's plan
and is working
to double-cross him?
If Alicia
can't trust the robbers
or her former friends
with the police,
she might try
taking the gold for herself.
One thing's for sure,
never underestimate
Alicia Sierra,
as she warns
The Professor herself.
There are no big battles
without big opponents.
Alicia has good reason
to be puzzled
by The Professor's plan.
One of the great mysteries
of the Bank of Spain heist
is exactly how the gang
plan to pull off
their audacious robbery.
We know for sure that Bogotá
has his smelting crew
turning the bank's gold
reserves into tiny pellets,
but that still leaves them
with thousands
of balls to transport.
Well, some fans
think The Professor
has already
explained the plan
and that he wasn't lying
to Sierra when he told her…
We're turning it to grit...
into...
two-millimeter nuggets
to get it out.
It would be bold to tell
your enemy your scheme,
but he could be relying
on Sierra not believing him,
which, conveniently,
she doesn't!
You think I'm stupid, right?
There are lots
of fan theories
about the robbers
using water
to transport
the gold nuggets
out of the Bank of Spain.
The fact that the main vault
is flooded with water
as a security measure
means that water eventually
needs to be flushed out,
and that could be the key
to removing the gold.
Other fans think this plan
has been foreshadowed
in Berlin's
Copenhagen robbery.
Having removed the Viking
gold from the vault,
Berlin throws it
into the river
to the dismay of Rafael.
But it was all part
of Berlin's master plan,
as his crew
later collect the gold
from the water
at a safer time.
Is this a dry run?
Well, more of a wet run,
for the Bank of Spain heist?
The other question is
how to get the team
out of the bank
with the gold.
You can't flush Helsinki
down a toilet.
One fan theory thinks the
plan is to get the gold out
and then hold it hostage
in exchange for the crew.
Tamayo tells us
again and again
how important the gold is.
The National Reserve
is a country's backbone.
Is Sierra's dignity
more important
than the safety of
47 million people?
If they're so scared of
tanking the Spanish economy,
surely that's got
to be worth the price
of a few bank robbers.
One really out-there
fan theory suggests the gold
isn't even
the primary target
in the Bank of Spain heist
and is a diversion
from the robbers' real goal.
This theory begins
in the Copenhagen flashback,
where Berlin
explains to Rafael
how to pull off
a crime with no risk.
So tell me, Dad,
what's a zero-risk robbery?
One that goes unnoticed
when you rob them.
Berlin's plan
to steal Viking gold
involves replacing priceless
pieces with brass replicas
so that the museum owners
won't realise
they've been robbed
for many months.
After all, you can't
be accused of a crime
that no one knows about.
Jump forward
to the Bank of Spain heist
and pay close attention
to the bank's museum.
We hear Denver and Palermo
discuss the value
of its treasure.
Why aren't we melting
all this gold?
This gold
was already stolen one.
It can't be stolen twice.
And when the special forces
are preparing
to blow up the roof
to gain access to the bank,
Ángel warns them
about damaging
the treasures within.
There are Goya paintings and
Quimbaya gold in there...
This theory believes
that The Professor
knows the special forces
will have no choice
but to blow the roof
to enter the bank,
destroying the paintings
and artifacts,
which gives him
an opportunity to steal them
without anyone realising.
Admittedly,
if this is the plan,
they've kept it quiet,
so quiet that Palermo and
Denver don't know about it.
But, hey, it wouldn't
be the first time
The Professor
has surprised everyone.
And those are just some
of the fan theories circling
one of the most
unpredictable shows around.
Come on,
did you ever picture Arturo
with a flamethrower?
Thought not.
With only a few months to go
before the second half
of Part 5 drops,
we've not long to wait.
But why not help
that time go faster
by sharing your own
Money Heist theories
in the comments below
and subscribing
to Still Watching Netflix
for more features about your
favourite movies and shows.